the question is whether the Prime
Minister will come up with anything
different at all and after a five-hour
meeting surely she can't just come out
and announce another run around the same
circle in terms of putting her same deal
but well you wouldn't put it past her
either
okay King bear with me bear bear with me
because I just you know why did he teach
a shout treason I mean what how does
that help she's how's that help she's
acting against the interest of the
country no she's doing what she thinks
is in the interests of the country I
mean you may disagree with that but why
do you feel out Jesus I'm not why do you
shout Cruz is acting against you and
true you disagree with her but why do
you score that treason that's not a
traitor that's what the word is look up
in the dictionary
you think that but other people might
say that you're Iran you can't just
called if I survived that's a violet
that's a difference of opinion but
you're shouting names at the prime
minister who's trying to come up with
the solution you think it's the truth we
have politics so people can mediate
between differences of opinion and
you're in you're saying your opinion if
you're gonna agree with your opinion
they're traitors how does that help we
live in a free country I'm allowed to
say that but how does it help the
process if you're coming here in the
video I don't give you the rights to
anything you could do whatever you want
to do but you're calling the Prime
Minister a traitor I'm saying because
she's working lines the interest of the
country
did you notice how comfortable she is
when she's with her friends in Brussels
how more comfortable she is when she's
in Europe compared to the place over the
road I don't notice that's all I just
thought I had to pick up the language
there we go so well okay some protesters
here you know it's become quite normal
using that type of language and I just
thought it was worth checking out
exactly why people feel it's okay to
call politicians
traitors news words like treason that
was his explanation probably bit more
all that as we go on now pass about to
you in Downing Street
finals how do you three shredded wheat
today